peu
[Musique]
dynastique des inouk
dans le cas où pendriez en cours de
route cette grande saga historique voici
un résumé des épisodes précédents
l'histoire se déroule dans une
principauté imaginaire situé à 30
kilomètres de nice à crapaud quel joli
crap bonjour notre peau intras quel joli
prince j'allais faire un bisou bonjour
le prince m'a bienfaitrice en
m'embrassant tu a rompu le sort qu'on
avait jeté sur mon berceau qu'elle était
beauté moi je fais partie la dynastie
des ebooks d'ebook quel est ton prénom
nadine maginot j'ai bien connu ta mère
ça s'appelle un coup de foudre le prince
lui l'ue va immédiatement demandé la
main de la belle nadine ebooks à son
père le roi devra partir pour jérusalem
chez mokhtar tu devras me ramener 2 kg
de boudin blanc dès que le prince lui
par pour jérusalem ne dîne se fait
enlever par le pesq à tort et son fidèle
akbar maclou ils l'entraînent dans son
harem et confins du désert
c
oui
à
[Musique]
jamila
pendant ce temps lui arrive à jérusalem
et rencontres kassim germes ou d'un
archi un boudin blanc
[Musique]
achats chez les bulls bien comme ça
pendant ce temps le pesq à tort commence
à saturer de la belle n'était ni mook et
essaye de la revendre le temps chambre
il la gandoura et brûlis je n'ai play
les bas rouges c'est mon coeur je peux
plus tendus l'ouvrier français blanc de
préférence je peux plus je peux plus je
fais quelque chose tout de suite à l'eau
les barras y ont très bien passé les
petites annonces le prince lui oublie
nadine amouk dans les bras des chats
écrasés
c'est toi la phrase qui tirait bien
celle de bachelard si je trouve plus con
que moi je veux tu pourras si tout ce
passe comme envers le disait plus con
que toi on gueule je peux pas je peux
pas vivre avec toi je peux plus rester à
alors je me casse je retourne chez
kassim avec lui au moins je pouvais
discuter avec lui au moins je pouvais
philosopher eh ben ça tombe bien parce
que je commençais moi aussi en avoir
marre claque
aïcha a écrasé lens rennes hadji bon
d'accord ça volait pas haut meaux -
l'embrasser elle pensait à la décoration
de la maison celle la branche est amer
tiens elle n'aura pas eu le temps
d'aller chez sa mère à lointain quand
même des noms prédestinés nt1 riesch a
écrasé sa écrasé voilà c'est tout d'où
l'expression populaire le gaver pendant
la suite qu'elle fit un pierre berger
allemand est à son tour mordu pour
nadine mercier quelques jolis berger
allemand
j'ai dû faire un petit bonjour les
bergers allemands bonjour et belle
enfant s'ils cohabitaient exactement les
gars de ta maison paix pâte hamelin wama
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma
le décor est planté les personnages
aussi où vous êtes maintenant fin prêt à
suivre la suite de cette grande saga la
dynastie des ebooks ne ratez pas dès
samedi prochain
votre grand feuilleton qui dromadaires
la dynastie des ming
[Musique]